so welcome delighted to have you guys
here really nice to be here thank you I
was gonna tell a story that my advisor
in graduate school used to tell
frequently when I was a student and it's
about Phineas Gage who was a railroad
construction guy in the 1860s early
1800s and he was working on the railroad
and at a certain point an accident
happened and he got a railroad tie
through the roof of his mouth and it
went through the front of his brain and
they brought him into the hospital they
cut it off at the top they didn't really
know what to do with him he healed up
they sent him home and so much about him
was the same he could remember
everything he went back to work he began
to do things thank you he and and for
many extents and purposes he was the
same person yet it damaged the frontal
lobe of his brain and there was one
thing this the frontal lobe is where we
process emotion and the one thing that
he couldn't do was make a decision now
there's an irony in that because when we
try to inform our decision-making
processes frequently we defer judgment
and defer the decision moment saying we
need more information we can't make that
decision and yet there's a cognitive
link between where that moment fires in
our brain that is the emotional part of
the brain that actually lights up and so
this for me was really it it was a
profound element and I'm sure it's an
element in all of our work because we
find ourselves very emotionally
committed to many of the things that we
do when we practice research and yet in
order to function as a researcher and
engage the analytical part of our brain
we need to shut that emotion off
frequently so then how do we then
re-engage the emotional parts and the
communication ability effectively the
entire part of our brain system in order
to be able to effectively communicate to
those people that need to effectively
inform taking information but also
register it find whether or not it's
resonant with personal value be able to
engage the emotional part of the brain
and then make a decision that's a very
complex process and it's something that
we're learning an awful lot about
recently and so it's my great pleasure
to present to you the team for me
community among other things today
because it's been some of the places
that we've been doing some of the more
wild and unpredicted experimenting with
the team for me effort where I come from
is Southeast Alaska
about as far away from here in the
United States as you can possibly get
and my reason for living there is
because I left high school and I was
taking care of my cousins when they were
very young and I became extremely
attached to the landscape the smells the
sights seasonality is incredibly intense
in Southeast Alaska and it allowed me to
notice things that were changing in the
ecological system around me now that's
something that happens with most people
around the world except for the fact
that there's a disturbing trend and that
is that more and more people and
especially more and more children are
spending time indoors and they're not
getting that kind of exposure on a
regular basis currently the average
American child spends seven and a half
hours watching some form of media per
day they spend an hour and a half
texting per day you know want to know
how much time they spend playing
outdoors every day anyone want to guess
average American child half hours ten
minutes four minutes the average
American child plays outdoors four
minutes a day now think about all the
kinds of decisions that were making
right now the generations that are
making these decisions on behalf of the
way in which we are managing our
collective natural resources are all
people that grew up effectively many of
them playing outdoors
so there's a disconnect between some
major social changes that are occurring
and the way in which we are emotionally
connected to the landscapes connected to
each other and also emotionally engaging
with our information and decision-making
processes these are all very complex
things that when you think about it at
Brant broad scale the mind tends to reel
a little bit things get a little bit out
of hand because you're joining
right-brain left-brain rational
irrational analytical emotional what do
you do with that so I'm going to tell
you today about an approach that I've
been using that I've been finding really
useful one of the assigned readings
today is a very short summary of a very
powerful piece of writing by Donella
Meadows that's very familiar to a lot of
people especially that our systems
analysts and so I'm going to introduce
that as a toolkit and then we're going
to talk about how we explored it a bit
through team for me this is just to make
the point that increasingly wilderness
and those places that are far out of
reach are getting fewer and fewer this
is a map of travel time to major cities
um systems thinking in acts the idea of
leverage did something bad happen
well if someone helps me with that I'll
just explain it it's as if your child
and you're on a playground and you're
playing teeter-totter and you're sitting
on one end of the teeter-totter and your
great big brother sits on the other end
of the teeter-totter and you're stuck
way up in the air and you have no way of
getting yourself down what you do you
get another friend to run up the other
side of the teeter-totter and sit with
you at the end of the teeter-totter to
bring your side down so you can get the
heck off and so the point here is is
that you have greater leverage in
certain parts of the system than others
and when we attack a very broad and
complex system we don't always act on
the most powerful elements of the system
that is to say if we can find elements
move ourselves a bit away from the
fulcrum that we can enact further
leverage and generally we spend a lot of
time in decision-making establishing
information about parameters numbers
feedbacks and so on this is the data and
the information piece and our newspapers
are replete with this kind of
information relatively less information
is talking to us about rules but they're
they're important ones these are major
legal innovations that kind of thing but
very rarely do we get information about
the kinds of things that are changing
with mindsets goals and aspirations
taking another look at the schema lost a
little bit of the formatting in the in
the different computer system here but
that outer layer this we call this the
onion model the outer layer of the onion
is where we have our parameters and
numbers then at the next layer is the
feedbacks and structure another deeper
layer after that is the the information
flows and how they're governed another
layer under that is the rules than the
goals and at the deepest layer the
mindset of the system how we are
reflecting our basic values how whether
or not we believe that a system can be
chained
and this is really important because
what if we are creating all of these
rules and we're attempting to do
something say come back climate change
but deep embedded in our mindset is the
belief that we can't do anything
fundamentally illustrating that it
doesn't matter how much information you
have about the system or how much
information is flowing around the system
or how many rules or laws or feedbacks
you've created in order to correct the
system if deep in the heart of the
system you've got a problem with mindset
it means that much of the change that
you're attempting to bring about will
not happen so that is to say when we are
working on strategic change with respect
to all of the elements that are in the
tape reports it's important to focus on
the structure and the layers of
information so that not only are we
informing the parameters and numbers but
that we are also thinking about how
people are taking in information at
progressively deeper layers of the
system in graduate school I entered
graduate school at the University of
Maryland at the Institute for ecological
economics this is where the cut stands a
lab was based and where some of the
first estimates for the value of natural
capital came out it was a very difficult
time and I say that not just because I
was a tortured graduate student but it
was a typical it was a difficult time
because these estimates of the values of
ecosystem services ran counter to a lot
of the mindsets of the way people
believed that value should be assigned
and putting a number on something or
making something visible was very much
like holding a lightning rod and from a
number of different perspectives this
was either unacceptable or began to not
reflect the the ways in which many
people thought about systems it was
especially challenging because total
economic value was generally assigned to
those elements on the far left-hand side
of the diagram the direct use benefits
the tangible elements of ecosystems
and ecological services oftentimes were
on the in the mid part of the diagram
where they were somewhat less tangible
they were less rival they were less
excludable therefore they were less
marketable and then that didn't even
begin to encompass all of these values
on the far right hand side the most
intangible values those that had were
about option value the quest value or
existence value and so as a result there
was almost a perfect storm of factors
being set up that we had a hard time
dealing with because we hadn't accounted
for all the diversity of ways in which
people could have interpreted forms of
value so different types of value there
are those instrumental values they might
be anthropocentric serving some kind of
a human end-use they might be functional
so that is to say they can't contribute
to the existence of another or they
might be intrinsic so that is to say
that they might have value in their own
right and reference to any other entity
isn't really required and the team
reports begin to show how all of these
values in a net whole are creating
benefit whether they're tangible or
intangible whether they are functional
or instrumental and so on
another thing that that we've been
dealing with with respect to making
changes in the value of ecosystem
services is laying out the goals ahead
of us for where we do want to go setting
the mindset for the kind of kindness of
change that we want to create
familiarity with this diagram I would
assume that many of you have encountered
it in in courses before so this is to
say this vertical axis is the ecological
footprint and the horizontal axis is the
Human Development Index so if we want to
consume at the level that the planet is
providing ecosystem services on an
annual basis
every year each person must consume at a
per capita level below this line if we
want to meet human Development Goals
everyone needs to be to the right of
this line making this particular box
particularly important and there's only
one country this was this graphic was
done I believe in 2005 by the global
footprint Network they make wonderful
visuals for communication only one
country in there I know somebody in the
audience knows who that is
no not Switzerland no not Germany no not
Iceland not Costa Rica now think about
how your answers are also reflective of
your mindset of what it means to be
successful or sustainable question some
of those assumptions to be to the right
of the line you have to provide lots of
medical aid you have to have low infant
mortality you have to have low petroleum
fuel consumption Cuba Cuba leading us to
turn on our heads a lot of our
assumptions about what our mindset is
about success so if this group of people
that are incredibly educated and
conscious of all these factors that are
leading to sustainability have certain
embedded assumptions about mindset of
what it means to be successful what does
that mean for the broader population and
how can we take that and use that
information to communicate more clearly
proving the point and Sally Collins who
was one of my mentors at the Forest
Service used to quote this a lot from
mark fields at the Ford Motor Company
culture eats strategy for breakfast so
our strategy is to try to become more
sustainable but our culture of making a
lot of assumptions about what that
success looks like really tends to
derail the way in which we are
approaching our problem strategy our
problem set up here so that leads to the
importance of why we are or are not
taking a systems-based approach
a system just to define it is a set of
things people cells molecules or
whatever that are all interconnected in
such a way that they produce their own
pattern of behavior over time so you
ever play that game where you guys stand
in a circle and you cross hands and then
you have to figure out how to get
yourselves out of that knot frequently
you think oh well maybe I should go over
that guy when in actual fact you have to
go under takes a lot of time to sort out
but principally another another useful
way of thinking about it is that
problems frequently can't be resolved at
the same level in which they're created
so the way to get yourself out of this
knot game is to have someone from the
outside looking in at a different scale
and saying well everything's
interconnected but what if we did this
and this so again just like the
concentric layers of the onion it helps
to take a different scale or perspective
in order to get a fresh look at the
system and the way it's interconnected
so principles of systems thinking the
art and science of making reliable
inferences about behavior means that you
have to understand increasingly deep
layers of the system improvement in one
area of the system can either positively
or adversely affect another area of the
system there's many unintended
consequences that happen in systems and
one way to diagnose those and to
counteract them is to map them out
another principle is small catalytic
events can cause very large changes in
complex systems and I think that the
actions that team for me has taken in
the past year to two years really shows
a lot of this and has attempted to act
upon this particular leverage point and
suggesting that we can strategically
seed relationships among parts within a
system and relating one system to
another and we can try to do that in a
country conscientious way to spread
information about the value of
ecosystems and the way in which we might
we might preserve them over time so I'm
going to go through a couple of layers
of the onion I'm going to start with
feedback loops so a feedback loop is
where you map out us
them you've got inputs and you've got
outputs and sometimes you've got an
element on the left-hand side sometimes
you've got an element of your output
coming back and affecting your input
that leads to a lot of problems and when
a systems thinker or any kind of person
that has a vision for the way things
might be in the future takes a look at
the future there's a perceived gap
between what the current level is and
what the desired level is and that you
can take actions to affect change in
order to close that gap over time but
what if you haven't mapped out a
complete map of the system what if
someone we're trying to fill up their
glass turning the faucet more and more
but what if there were a giant hole in
the glass this is exactly what's
happening with ecosystem services right
now we are attempting to address
ecosystem services by delivering more
and more or at least stemming the losses
of ecosystem services but it's very hard
to communicate how demands for ecosystem
services are effectively causing a
bigger and bigger hole in the cup here
so in that sense there's a certain
extent to which we can turn our faucet
to the right but if we don't stem the
demands for ecosystem services at the
same time we're not taking a full
systems perspective so this is a map of
how payments for ecosystem services
function I know that all of you are
familiar with those principles so I'm
not going to dwell on this but again in
flow state of the system out flow you
have a perceived state and you have your
goal and you have a discrepancy you want
to influence both the inflows and the
outflows in order to take a systemic
view of correcting the system with
ecosystem services if we have a stock of
natural capital and we can say that
there is a supply of ecosystem services
and in general there is regenerative
capacity in that ecosystem over time
that is to say nature
to rejuvenate itself and on the right
hand side we've got ecosystem service
demand that feeds human well-being and
we've got behavioral choices that modify
the side of the system the map here the
weight payments for ecosystem services
are currently addressing this is by
seeing a perceived scarcity acting on
investment and having a payment for
ecosystem service responds to scarcity
the main goal there is to slow the loss
of ecosystem services by investing in
natural capital what that doesn't do is
address all the leakages to the system
that is to say the increasing rate in
which we are consuming ecosystem
services so that is to say that there's
price and information that should be
acting in order to govern ecosystem
service uses as things get more scarce
price generally should rise but we know
that that's not the case
with ecosystem services and the teeb
reports underscore that mainly because
many of the characteristics the
market-based characteristics for
ecosystem services neither reflect rival
rival potential or excludable potential
and it doesn't account for the full
suite of values that are being reflected
so that is to say that there's different
ways of acting on the system in order to
maintain stocks of natural capital in
perpetuity over time next leverage point
information flows I have been fascinated
by the way in which information has
spread this is a map I don't have it
sighted here yet
but it's a map of all of the connections
amongst individuals on Facebook
worldwide and we can think about the
ways in which there's flows of
information that occur amongst different
people in different countries amongst
different continents north and south and
so on there are many opportunities here
for connecting information flows either
through social media or
electronic means and so on and we've
been talking a lot about those but how
to strategically invest in those
networks is an entirely different
question it's not just about facebook as
all of you know there's numbers of
different kinds of networks for example
each color here represents a different
major or most popular social network in
any given country
so China is its using Q's own currently
there's a Orkut is very popular in
Brazil hi-5 is another very popular
network that was emerging in Asia and so
just because many people in the United
States are interacting on a social
network like Twitter or Facebook doesn't
mean that the whole world is however
many of our assumptions about who is
being active on these networks is
oftentimes not accurate for example the
world's largest user of Twitter right
now is Indonesia and they're accessing
those networks basically on mobile
phones this is a map of the percentage
of 10 to 14 year old girls who are
following two or more years behind grade
grade for age and the point I'm making
here is that information can flow north
to south east to west and to certain
factions of society and the way in which
we invest in information flows allows
access to certain factions either gender
race and other kinds of disparities
there's two particular pyramids on the
left there are the demographics for
developed countries and on the right are
the demographics for developing
countries and I put this graph in the
presentation to underscore how important
it is that we are seeding information
amongst the most young cross-section of
the developing world because investments
when we think about systems intervention
over time as they develop if we
intervene at those age brackets down
here remember what I said about the
amount of media
use at this age as these brackets get
older we're going to see a very
different distribution amongst people of
information engaging new and emerging
information networks through social
media is a very different task than it
used to be on the left is communications
media goals and on the right is social
media goals the difference is is that on
the left the space is defined by the
media owner and on the right this space
is defined by the consumer abruptly
changing all of the ways and mindsets in
the way all of these feedbacks and flows
are functioning this has a lot of
implications for who is in control be it
the brand or the consumer and currently
social media tools are less about
blasting out information but more about
listening and conversation it's less
about the trendiest technology and more
about meeting people where they happen
to be and who they happen to be
associating with it's less about telling
people what's good and it's more about
helping people pass on good information
it's less about getting the message out
to the world and more about broadening
and connecting and strengthening spheres
of influence so this is a screenshot of
the bank of natural capital website and
have you visited that show of hands yeah
great so there's a different flow of
information here and I guess this was an
experiment in getting information about
natural capital out to the public at
large as you know each one of the D
reports do 0 1 2 3 were all in paper
reports and d4 was teeb for citizens how
many of you have ever written a paper
and work all nighters and infested your
heart into it and gotten it out your
professor read it you got it back and
there it sat on the shelf how many of
you have fears about
for perhaps your thesis everyone I
wonder that about my dissertation too I
wonder that a lot about the journal
articles that I spend a heck of a lot of
time writing and one day rich Howarth
who you met on Tuesday sent me a journal
article to review for the Journal of
ecological economics because it sounded
like something I'd done my dissertation
on and I read the abstract I said sure
I'll review that gosh darn it if someone
hadn't plagiarized lock stock and barrel
my entire abstract the whole article
switched the names of the towns and sent
it into the Journal of ecological
economics and just happened to arrive on
my desk for a peer review and I know
that my job is a scientist and I'm
supposed to reproduce information I
shouldn't keep plugging on that goal but
emotionally I was devastated about this
and I thought I if I can spend all this
time writing my dissertation and nobody
uses that information but it can also be
plagiarized so easily how am I supposed
to make an impact in the world and
personally speaking I was so
disheartened that I thought there's got
to be another way
enter Twitter conscientious goals to put
out information and your objective there
is to get as many people as possible to
retweet and effectively plagiarize
arevery every word with intention so
this seemed like a really fun direction
to go after that particular thing it
turned out that with the scientific
journal articles I had to take about a
year of reframing my approach to what
was going to be most effective but in
the meantime my investment in the social
media world allowed me to continue to
put out information continue to look at
systems analytically and maybe take a
different tactic delivering information
that over time we're still trying to
figure out how to report that in a
structured sense but for me it's been a
really rewarding experience so team for
me this views are very old numbers on
Twitter it's got probably about 5,000
followers
right now folks are tweeting in about 19
different languages in 1667 different
countries obviously no one none of the
interns or anyone that's working on
these tweets can translate that much but
again growing the spheres of influence
it's possible to translate not only in
language relevance but also in
application and make local ties in ways
that teeb the team core group the team
affiliates directly could never do and
so there's a there's a real power here
in the future about who is getting
information and how and these users tend
to be about 25 to 34 years old in in the
most active age groups we would have
liked to have had younger individuals
but it's difficult to attract those that
are under 18 but we found a couple of
different ways to engage them we've done
experiments with different ways in which
we might frame information and get it
out to the public the beautiful thing
about Twitter is that you can take the
exact same piece of information and you
can tweet it out in a positive way you
can be really excited exclamation point
happy face you can make a negative tweet
you can be moan the loss of something
and you can present neutral information
and you can see how all of these things
affect uptake of information and how
much that is retweeted passed forward
obviously much like Facebook there's a
reason why Facebook only has a like
button it's because psychologically
speaking people don't like to dislike
things and this is a really important
message for communicating much of the
issues about ecosystem services because
the story we continue to tell is a story
about loss and emotionally speaking
there are psychological barriers to
taking and repeated in repeated amounts
of information about loss there are
reasons why we wall that off and as a
result if we're providing people
information about loss and
they consequently are shutting down the
emotional parts of their brain they will
not be able to engage those emotional
parts of their brain in engaging a
decision to take a change for the
difference in the future so ironically
there's a fourth option positive
messaging negative messaging neutral
messaging the fourth one and the most
effective one is giving people
information about what their nearest
neighbors are doing and perhaps this is
because it interacts at some level on
some kind of evolutionary competition
that the feature that we have in our
wiring people like to hear about what
their neighbors are doing what your
classmates are doing in terms of carbon
footprint electricity use so on and so
forth
Japan waged a very effective campaign
about reduction of electricity use as
did Juneau Alaska when Avalanche took
out the hydro generators and everyone
had to go on diesel by giving people
information about what their neighbors
were doing in Great Britain in London
someone went along the street gave
everyone energy meters and then went on
the street and spray-painted the amount
of wattage that each household was using
making a very visible point about who's
using what over time these are very
creative ways about giving people
information that are very effective
cognitively in stimulating change in
forward going action we but obviously
there's different ways in which
information might be popular or be
relevant to the task at hand one of the
most popular posts on the team from your
Facebook feed was a video of baby sloths
people love sloths and for whatever
reason it was extremely popular but it
was a stretch for us to give it some
contextual relevance so there's a lot of
work to be done in finding a mix of the
really fun stuff how many of you have
seen the quick videos or the the
commercials or advertisements that we
put out working in conjunction with mo
film
the little things yeah a few of you so
they're available on the team for me
website little things and also the
nature's invoice there they're different
ways of reaching people that combine
heavy-hitting information with also
alternative paths for the future in a
way that's very entertaining and this is
a big frontier out there so if any of
you are interested in this it's a career
direction I think there's a lot of
potential next layer of the onion is to
talk about goals I'm going to introduce
this information here because it's a
very effective way to talk with the
public about that right-hand side of the
feedback loop the the leak the leak in
the the cup that I was talking about it
before the tea propor talked about this
concept in vague terms about living off
the planets interest it's the idea that
everyone has you want to make enough
money that you're living off the
interest in your in your banking account
it's the way we define what it means to
be independently economically wealthy at
this point if the planet has a certain
stock of natural capital and has an
annual flow of ecosystem services per
year as a global community we must
consume only this amount of ecosystem
services or fewer as a global whole if
we consume more ecosystem services than
that we are eating into our stocks of
natural capital so this concept how much
of the ecosystem services we are using
has to do on the right hand side the
ecological footprint that last image was
from the global footprint Network again
geniuses with diagrams and communication
the right hand side consuming ecosystem
services and the left hand side the
supply of ecosystem services are not
congruent and so nature's interest
- humanity's footprint
equals our ecological surplus or our
ecological debt this is a map that's
been especially popular many social
media spheres again global footprint
Network showing us in red ecological
debt and in green ecological surplus by
country
this is 1961 what it looked like
this is 2005 and imagine the trajectory
where we're going in the future so this
is one way to get across this concept of
ecosystem services and making the
connection between a stock of natural
capital and a flow of ecosystem services
and the different things that we can do
in order to shore up our ecological debt
over time this the reason why I give
this lead up is because this diagram was
the result of a competition that teeb
Fermi put out in conjunction with
visualizing org so that is to say all of
the data from teeb was available to
different data visualization innovators
and a number of different case studies
were put up it was opened up to a
crowdsourcing competition and this was
the winner this is an interactive tool
it's on it's linked to by the team for
me website and also by going into the
visualizing org website you can also get
to this page and this is an interactive
tool so as you mouse over different
countries you can compare among two
different countries on the left and it
will show you ecological footprint
information at the same time it will
also show you this dynamic between the
ecological capacity the ecological
footprint and the resulting deficit of
every country that you mouse over it's a
fun little tool to play with and also
when you're comparing among different
country it will generate reports
comparing among ecosystem services
basically saying if
everyone consumed like an average person
in say Brazil or the United States this
is how many planets we would need in
order to support those lifestyles
another very effective communication
tool has been the story of stuff
obviously a cartoon based way to
describe ever the way in which we
extract Natural Resources fabricate them
into products bring them to
manufacturing consume them in the
household and then the output to into
our waste systems and this is element of
the circular economy or the full cost
accounting that might be done and many
of the different recommendations from
different elements of team talk about
accounting for and making visible all of
the ecosystem service impacts that are
both supporting each part of this and
that are and effectively paying the
price of many of these over time or at
least accounting for them in the
decision making processes
so effectively influencing how we
consume how we invest how we produce how
we sell but ultimately also how we plan
for the use of ecosystem services over
time another image the ecological
footprint of imports to the European
Union from the top 20 trading partners
again we can show in a visual way where
all of our ecosystem services are coming
from and it allows for a mindset shift
about where our different ecosystem
services need to be paid for in order to
or accounted for in order to in order to
preserve the system this is an image
from world map org and it's a map each
country is a different color obviously
this is a map of net country timber
imports so it's imports - exports United
States obviously on the right hand side
there is Japan we've got Australia down
here
Indonesia is very small Brazil and
Africa
obviously in red and green
and this is forest losses so Indonesia
has some of the most rich but also some
of the most fine layers of soil on the
planet and yet it is losing losing
forest cover at some of the fastest
rates in the world leading to also
fourth most populous country Indonesia
again and ironically this is also the
country that is the most active in
Twitter usage there are networks of
information and there are trends and
patterns that are forming it's possible
to suggest that there's a strategic
intervention at hand here but we have
yet to exactly identify what that is and
may progress toward it which leads us to
the next layer of the system at the core
of the system we need to question many
many of our assumptions at a fundamental
level and we need to be able to pass and
engage more kinds of information that
allow people to effectively over time
broaden their spheres of concern this is
Laura Barbie a @ Barbie A's daughter in
the Botanic Gardens in Great Britain
with a QR code
lots of familiarity with QR codes and a
bet amongst you but effectively people
can snap pictures with their personal
technology or telephones taken
information rapidly digital information
and up will pop up a whole host of
information now imagine if it were
possible to walk into say a lumber store
any of our major distributors and you
want to buy a desk what if the product
on the shelf had a QR code that when you
snapped a picture of it immediately
brought you to a case study of all of
the ecosystem service values and
information and the places and people in
which the this particular production
process impacted it's a way of
connecting the consumer
to information about the product but
also acting on different layers of the
cognitive connections that can then
inform a consumer decision one of the
major problems we have with being able
to invoke different choices in consumer
decisions is that information just gets
too complex for people or they might be
doubtful about the reliability of the
information that they're getting or they
might not have it in the immediacy of
the moment in which they're about to
make that decision it's possible to
connect all of these dots if we
strategically target it and I'd suggest
that it's possible to take a look at
each one of your projects and think
about for the semester not just about
the different pieces of information that
you might have at the more superficial
layers of the system but also ask
yourselves is it possible to get
consecutively deeper into the system and
ask yourself what is the predominant
mindset about the problem that you have
in front of you and what tools do you
have at hand either real tools or
potential tools or even imaginary tools
tools that you think the might the next
generation might have in order to
connect all of these different layers of
information and propose an alternate
future obviously it's not there's no
Peniche a-- with serve with serving up
all of these these different solutions
one of the big barriers is the digital
divide and this is a global download
study of how fast people can download
information worldwide showing that on
the order of two thousand is really
different than say 13 and so who has
information and how quickly they are
able to access it is a big barrier but
at the same time we also need to note
that there are currently
5.3 billion mobile subscribers in the
world
Pavin has noted that he's an outlier
because he has three but case in point
3.8 billion mobile units are in the
developing world so when we think about
the kind of technology where there is a
digital divide and many of the different
efforts say for example the
hundred-dollar computer was a noble
effort to get information in the hands
of those that most need it in order to
make progress on our global Development
Goals but it's also possible to
completely rethink it the way in which
we are communicating and delivering
information and connecting these
communities of influence in such a way
that we can shift the mindset in a
coordinated fashion and bring about an
alternate solution so three big concepts
for the future that currently remain a
challenge obviously many of you are
familiar with this diagram the from the
Millennium ecosystem assessment
describing the ways in which we
characterize all of the different kinds
of ecosystem services supporting
provisioning regulating cultural on the
left and then all the ways in which we
benefit on the right but one of the main
contributions of the teeb report is
showing how value exists in all of these
different quadrants on the upper axis is
whether or not a good or service is
excludable if for example I can charge
to access a scenic viewpoint if I've
made somebody pay five dollars to get
through the gate can I exclude everyone
that hasn't paid that amount rival if
one person consumes a good or service is
someone else able to consume the other
good or certain the same amount of good
or service or does it diminish over time
for example if I eat a piece of pizza
there's not a piece of pizza left over
for pollen to eat so there
it gives me extra incentive to pay money
for eating that piece of pizza
most ecosystem services currently lie in
this lower right-hand corner this is an
old paper by Randall it's very
fundamental to categorizing and
explaining why ecosystem services and
the market sphere are very visible
markets can account for them we can
witness transaction cost and
transactions occurring with them GDP is
especially impacted in that blue
quadrant however most ecosystem services
on a planetary level are provided in the
public their pure public goods so as a
result if we don't account for value in
a visible way in each one of these
sectors we are unable to make effective
provisioning and and shore up our
institutions in such a way that we're
actually able to provide them
efficiently and in perpetuity second
concept overshoot I I think it was just
yesterday that I received an email from
the global footprint Network saying it's
the overdraft notice saying if we
consumed worldwide all of the available
ecosystem services over the year at a
certain point where along the Year
Humanity is going into overdraft and
that day is coming earlier and earlier
every year this is a concept which if
yes yes 1987 1990 95 2000 2005 and then
the most recent one is 2008 so it
doesn't account for the current date
which which leads us to the final point
and this is particularly important for
our agencies when we are thinking about
how we make decisions because as Pavan
just mentioned at the beginning and as
rich covered talking about the discount
rate a dollar in the present day is not
either cognate
or realistically the same as a dollar in
the future however our natural capital
is just as relevant if not more to the
population today as it will be in the
future so as a result we need to be
treating our decision processes on
different time frames and frequently
public agencies have things like annual
budgets you get your your allocation
from Congress you have one year to spend
it if you don't spend it within that
calendar year you probably lose it if
you spend it in such a way that that it
saves things like energy or say you pay
money for recycling frequently money
goes back to the Treasury as a whole and
we don't have those feedback systems
that are bringing incentive back to
those decision-makers so that they can
keep the savings for themselves thus
they're not they're making the best
decisions for individual units but with
respect to the entire system over time
we're seeing the same processes of
overdraft occurring so what that means
is we need to be correcting feedback
loops in who is getting the incentive
and when they're getting it we also need
to think about time horizons imagine for
example if you're going to decide should
I rent an apartment this year or should
I take the leap and buy a house this
year the first year you make that
decision you are down in the red and if
everyone were making their all of their
decisions and this is currently how
we're making our decisions about natural
capital we don't want to make the
decision to buy that house invest in
that infrastructure or build up our
stocks because in the immediate term and
emotionally we are seeing that as being
in the red without the ability to see
the long-term and the systemic
perspective and also emotionally and
cognitively calculate and anticipate
that break-even date right where the
gray turns to red here to pink and from
that point especially we aren't able to
calculate the payoffs especially for
future generations talking about what
does the shape of this
look like do we get just a little boost
or is it actually exponential once we
start breaking even oftentimes with
natural capital investments we find that
small amounts of investment very early
on in the system lead to very large
profit margins in many senses in the
long run so I know that taking on all of
this especially the emotional
psychological systemic and mindset love
layers to your projects are especially
difficult and without taking a strategic
and concerted approach to each one of
those layers of the system we risk
losing some of the most important
drivers and elements at the very core so
start what you where you are do what you
can and use the gifts you have thank you
you